nadir poy and her three-year-old son
were on this train when it left
Bangladesh's Northern District of netron
late on Monday they never made it three
carriages caught fire just before the
train arrived in Dhaka four people were
killed nad's husband broke down while
talking to the
media we want Justice whoever committed
this heinous crime must be punished my
family is all gone we couldn't even see
the bodies we want the bodies Return To
Us in recent weeks the main opposition
Bangladesh and nationalist party and its
allies are blocking public transport and
calling General strikes supporters want
the government to step down ahead of
next month's elections authorities have
condemned the attack and blame the
opposition those who called strikes are
involved in these arson attacks and
sabotage they are doing this at the
directive of foreign agents through
their local counterparts and followers
this is
clear but the opposition alleges the
government is behind the
sabotage the day before the incident we
came across documents from the police
which were sent to the health director
General notifying doctors and hospitals
to be on standby the question is why a
lawyer's Forum says more than 20,000
opposition party members and supporters
have been arrested since late October
and at least six have died in prison
several trains have been set on fire or
vandalized in the ongoing political
turmoil in Bangladesh however this is
the first time people have been killed
analysts and critics say it's
disappointing to see tragedies been
politicized before a thorough
investigation has taking place T Chri Al
jazer
Daka make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer